[Music]
all right let's go to lydia in seattle
washington what's up lydia how we doing
i'm doing good how are you john good i'm
kind of a mess today i'm getting there
you're gonna be on the show that people
are like what is that guy
doing i'm not drinking it's too early in
the morning but
i'm a bit of a mess but now i'm all back
in i just took my deep breath we're
re-centered and all that zen what's up
lydia
i need to do that too i'm nervous i'm
trying to tell myself i'm just like
talking to a friend oh number one we're
super friends number two
clearly by the first five minutes of
this show i
i don't know what i'm doing so you do
not have anything to be nervous about at
all i'm kind of nervous to talk to you
okay
i'm from seattle okay so what's up let's
do this
um nothing i've just kind of been
feeling well okay i'm 26 married i have
three kids um
secret my husband's my best friend
and we have a great group of friends i
want to preface that i love my group of
friends that i have
um
i just would also like some
new friends i guess like maybe people
that i connect with in other ways
and it's just
i gave you my background because it's
kind of
i guess hard to make friends
like i don't know
where or how or
you know with
i guess the group of friends that i have
um
they've just we've been friends with
them for a long time a lot of the girls
that i am friends with are you know
significant others of my husband's
friends and just because we've been
together
you know since we were like 18. um it's
just who i've been surrounded by
and i think now my kids are getting
you know in like the toddler phase so i
can't i have more flexibility to you
know
go out and do stuff on my own or
you know like
i don't
i i hey here's what you're allowed to
say lydia number one
what you're articulating is so hard and
i get that i get that
and
you're allowed to say
i don't like my husband's friends that
much or you're allowed to say
i
they're default friends like they're
just my friends because they're always
there and so what's up and suddenly our
kids are playing with their kids and i
don't like how they talk to their kids
their kids are weird or gross or they
don't
and all that starts to add up especially
you've got three kids and i imagine at
26 you're in kind of an uh
little sliver of life where
not a lot of 26 year olds have the
stress of three kids they still have
their special doodle dog and their one
kid
and they're like oh my gosh it's so much
and you're looking at them like how
about i burn your house down or
people with 30 with three kids
are like 40 or they're 35 and they're
like oh yeah you're so cute and they pat
you on the head and you're like listen
yeah i got three kids too idiot
and yeah your husband's totally right
bro let's just have cheetos and burritos
and let's go get them and by the way
cheetos and burritos rhymed and i've
never done that before until just now
so you find yourself lydia on an island
all by yourself is that fair
yeah yes and no i think my husband even
feels it too like these are people he's
been friends with for a long time but he
has different interests so we feel it on
like two different levels we are both
feeling this personally and we're also
feeling it as a couple
okay so that's actually
that's awesome because y'all are in this
together now because i've had
experiences where
wife wants to break up with friend group
and husband's like what's wrong they're
they're my bros and she's like
you're an idiot and they're okay so let
me ask you a hard question
why don't y'all start doing other things
together and inviting new different
people
well i guess it's just kind of like who
you know like we have i think we need to
like overall meet new people
yes so
yeah so it's just kind of like i guess
we just need to
go out and try new things and just
hopefully meet people that's just
intimidating and like
hard yes
so do either of y'all work
yeah we both work do either of you
like
do things in the community like have a
softball team or uh i don't know like
like a i don't know a club of some sort
or anything like that
no and that's kind of what i've been
thinking about too i think we need to
get out and you know start doing things
in the community and also what i was
thinking to our kids are getting older
you know like they're going to start
playing sports and
or like
music or dance or something like that so
he actually told me that the other day
he's like you know you'll probably meet
like other moms and
you know people that you might have in
common so
and what i would say is yes and and yes
and is
you'll be around them it will still be
awkward it'll still be weird one of you
will still have to say
hey i'd love to get together
one of you will have to say hey you and
your husband come over to my house bring
your kids and he's like well i got a
seven year old then a two-year-old and
then
we have this
magical one-year-old now that we didn't
plan i mean that will happen and you'll
be like i don't care come over and i'm
not cleaning my house by the way because
this is just how we roll this is the
kind of friends i want to have that i
don't have to clean my house for
and you all get to decide that so you
are going to be around people and it'll
be like
you know preschool kids or kindergarten
kids that you know hey i want to have
three
dads and moms over and their little kid
yeah all that is super true so what i
would tell you is you're at a natural
transition point where this is about to
start happening
and it is uncomfortable i'll just like i
experience it with my my closest friends
all of a sudden you don't think it's
like mean to your current friends like i
don't wanna it's not like i don't wanna
be friends with them like i feel like
guilty in a way sort of yeah no no not
at all i get what you're saying but not
at all people just grow and things
change and they morph and
what ends up happening is you end up
drowning yourself in your own
expectations and your own guilt
yeah and that guilt turns to resentment
so choose guilt every time it's okay to
feel guilty but you're not breaking up
with anybody
and it's okay to grow and to want new
things especially when you're doing it
in concert with your partner with your
husband there
yeah y'all are doing this together and
so there will still be the once a year
that you get together with all the old
idiots that's cool
um and that once a year or maybe twice a
year becomes once a year and then it
becomes hey we're gonna go do this thing
i experienced this
when
two of my best friends in the world we
all start having kids
and then suddenly
one of my best buddies became like i'm
all in little league person
like i think about little league that's
all i talk about i think about it i'm
like planning strategies for a little
league i go to the ball fields on
saturday mornings and i go like i live
there all day i watch the other kids i'm
scouting the other seven-year-olds
and
then i've got one buddy who became like
a uh cub scout dad
i was like what i
and yeah like we just have different
interests and then i was like a
idiot dad i want to go play in the woods
all the time and they were like deloney
how here's this cool thing called the
21st century why don't you live in that
and i'm like i know but what if we right
and so
i
love them
like love these guys i love their wives
they're close
and we all just kind of naturally
started doing things that were of
interest to us and our particular kids
and our families
and so we get together once a year and
now i live in a different state now that
we get together once a year but i i
don't begrudge the fact that man he
loves to go to the ball fields all day
that's kind of their thing that's not me
and my kids think me and my kids thing
is to go play in the mud and go in the
creeks and go hunting a lot
and they're not big hunters that's
awesome so that naturally happens
what's not okay
is if i start
not liking them because life is gently
nudging them in other directions if i
begrudge them then they're not really my
friends i'm trying to hold them into a
picture of what i want our friendship to
be
and the same thing applies for you okay
you'll have three kids you all start
leaning other directions you start
hanging out and then your friends like
oh my gosh you abandon us you never hang
out with it
well then they're actually yeah that's
what it they're acting like
four-year-olds don't they're not they
can't trap you like that
okay um
and
you have to be intentional about finding
new community because you're going to
get really lonely
yeah and it's awesome to be married to
your best friend that's the best way to
do it and you still have to have other
people that are just yours
okay because y'all will pull each other
underwater
i talked to too many executives across
the country who use their spouses as
trash cans
here's all the crap that happened to me
today because the only other human they
interact with all day
the
my husband he is my best friend and we
genuinely we love doing things together
we just you know there's certain things
where
we want to do you know with
a group me a girlfriend and him and you
know another guy
absolutely absolutely
i want to free you from any burden you
feel that you are stuck in this thing
forever you are not okay
yeah i think i just needed someone to
tell me it's okay you know to like try
to go make other friends without
offending
the ones that we have now not only is it
okay
it's the right healthy loving wonderful
great thing to do
not only is it the right wonderful i
don't remember all those words i just
used not only is it important but your
marriage depends on it
your parenting depends on it
so think of it as we have to start
exercising or we have to start eating
right or we have to
have some sort of faith context in our
life we have to be on the same page with
parenting think of it that and we have
to go to work and earn money so we can
eat think of it it's that important that
we have to create new friendships and
here's the words i want you to hang on
to i want you to
choose guilt over resentment have you
ever heard me say that
no okay
choose guilt
if somebody asks you
hey we want you to hey we're all getting
together to do this thing and your first
thought is i don't want to go hang out
with y'all
you will feel guilty for not going those
first few times you say no
yeah you will feel guilty when they call
you like what we missed you why didn't
you come you never have else anymore and
you're like yeah we're just spending
some family time or we were hanging out
with some friends from someone's from
zoe's dance class
you'll feel guilty and that's normal
that's fine
choose that every time over choosing
resentment and that is you don't want to
go your husband doesn't want to go you
don't want your kids around their kids
but you go anyway because you feel this
yeah that's exactly
and you you hate you hate getting ready
for it you hate driving over there you
hate being there and then you hate the
drive home and then you and your husband
are whining and complaining to each
other
choose guilt every time over resentment
because i feel like the guilt will go
away but the resentment won't the
resentment turns ever it's it's like
coals on a fire it just burns everything
to ash
and it's hard to come back from
resentment and that resentment
breeds
dissension in your marriage
and your kids feel it
and so sometimes i'm like if he doesn't
want to go it's like come on like
let's just go only be there for an hour
or something like that and you want to
do that because you think you're
supposed to that you have a dude
no you have a duty to take care of your
family and sleep and laugh and enjoy
this guy you'll have three kids and
you're only 26. if you've got a night
that you can just hang out with your
husband and y'all can look at each other
like you're gross 18 year olds again do
that
don't go hang out with idiots you know
what i mean
you you are right in the right spot
lydia asking the right questions doing
the right things and get some friends
that are older
get like
like me and my wife waited two years
later to have kids and she hangs out
with lots of people that are five years
younger than her 10 years younger than
her and it's awesome it's super fun
um and i think it's good for the younger
folks to be around someone who's older
and wiser not that i'm saying my wife's
old but she's a thousand
or
it's good for my wife to realize i'm not
so
old i can still hang with i can hang
with the young kids i can hang with the
kids it's good for everybody
you get to exchange wisdom and
excitement and fun and we get to learn
who post malone is i didn't know that
was whatever but cool great question
lydia thank you so much go make new
friends make them all the time always be
making new friends